بالموت والدمار سبق ان هدد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في حال تم
اعتقاله لكن سيناريو اعتقاله لا يبدو
واردا الا في حال رفض ترامب الاستسلام
والخضوع لطلب الحضور امام المحكمه وهو ما
يقول محاميه انه مستعد للامتثال له
وتمهيدا للمتول امام الادعاء الثلاثاء
المقبل سيصل ترامب الى نيويورك قادما من
فلوريدا علامه طائرته الخاصه الاثنين على
ان يقضي ليلته في برجه في نيويورك ويتوجه
بعدها ليواجه متوهم به في اولى مراحل
الادعاء حسب مقربين منه تحدث لوكاله
بلومبرج وتلقي هذه الاجراءات بظلال من
القلق على مدينه نيويورك التي تتاهب للحدث
فشرطتها المحليه وشرطه الولايه ووكالات
الفيدراليه مستنفره امنيا تاهبا لما يمكن
ان يرافق حضور ترامب امام الادعاء من
مظاهرات او اعمال عنف من انصاره الذين
دعاهم للاحتجاج دعما له وانتزاع البلاد
ممن يصفهم ترامب
اما الاجراءات المتوقع ان يخضع الرئيس
السابق لها لدى وصوله الى المحكمه فهي
قراءه التهم الموجهه اليه ثم اخذ بصماته
والتقاط صوره عرضيه وطوليه لملامحه وهو ما
لم يخضع له رئيس الامريكي قبله ويواجه
ترامب في هذه القضيه وحدها اكثر من 30
اتهاما حسب مصادر اطلعت على تفاصيلها
ويتوقع بعد ذلك ان يسمح له بالانصراف في
انتظار ان تبدا المحاكمه بعد اسابيع او
اشهر وهذا ان بدات المحاكمه اصلا حيث يجوز
للقاضي ان يصرف القضيه ان لم يقتنع
بمبررات الادعاء او امراه بان دوافعها
سياسيه ولا تقف مزاعمها على ارضيه صلبه
اما اذا اقتنع القاضي باسوس القضيه فيمكن
بعدها ان تبدا المحاكمه التي قد تاخذ
اسابيعها واشهرا وعلى الادعاء فيها اثبات
ان ترامب خرق القانون عن قصد لاستصدار
الادانه والحكم عليه